and let's get to the non-falter all
fodder that we have going on this week
the julio jones situation it's
it's i believe going to culminate in
something next wednesday that's when the
cap
charge for trading julio jones would
plummet to a point where it's manageable
for the falcons to do it you wrote back
the monday before the draft that that's
the direction where this is heading
peter i'm having a hard time identifying
who's interested in him
sims has said all week that he's
interested in the titans and the
patriots
there was a report yesterday from diana
russini of espn
which was then broadcast by the falcons
website
that the falcons have an offer of a
first round pick on the table for julio
jones my reaction that
is if they have it why the hell haven't
they accepted it yet and i'd love to
know how much of
his salary they have to pay to get a
first round pick he's due to make
15.3 million fully guaranteed but what's
your current thought
on where this all stands and where this
is all heading
well i don't i would be surprised if
they had a first-round pick
on the table for julio jones
because what you just said is right that
trade would be done right now
if they had a first round pick uh on the
table for julio jones
i doubt they're going to get a first
round pick now
they might and they also might get a two
that could become a one
with performance related bonuses or
uh you know a two that could become a
one in an
easier fashion you know with less
uh you know with less you know sort of
performance related bonuses
but it wouldn't be for a couple of years
um
i think they're probably gonna end up
getting a two next year
uh and i i think i just think
that and look i was with uh
you know the brain trust of the falcons
on draft night okay
so i i got the impression from terry
fontenot
and from arthur smith the general
manager and coach
that they were gonna be solid that they
needed
a solid two to get this thing done
and obviously they wanted a one and who
knows
maybe someone will pay him a one but
at the end of the day i think it's more
likely it's going to be a two
without any financial tentacles in other
words
obviously if you're a team out there and
you're trading for a guy
who's owed 38 million over the next
three seasons
if you're trading for that guy you want
and he only played nine games last year
he doesn't practice much anymore
if that is what you want you know you're
not going to pay
any of his salary going forward and the
falcons
i believe don't want to pay any of his
salary or
any of his his bonus money going forward
more than they already have to pay
contractually
the odds have moved dramatically this
week points bet now has new england is
the favorite at plus 150 tennessee plus
200.
they weren't even in the top three i
believe
earlier this week but it seems to be
coalescing around
those two teams there was a report last
weekend that the
patriots have had internal discussions
about julio jones and
i i usually react to those reports by
saying well they're not going to move
then because if they really wanted him
we wouldn't know about it isn't that how
it goes with the patriots we had no idea
they were having internal discussions
about cam newton
until they signed cam newton so maybe
those internal discussions led to the
conclusion that this doesn't fit
where we currently are and we've
upgraded our weapons sufficiently that
we don't
want or need to make this investment and
oh by the way we were just burned a
couple of years ago by sending a second
round pick to the falcons for a receiver
not that muhammad sunu is in the class
of julio jones and i really do think
peter that
second rounder the falcons got for
muhammad sunu
is an impediment here because they want
at least a two
because they got it too for a lesser
player at the same position
well my first reaction when i heard that
patriots report
that they have had internal discussions
about julio jones
my reaction is well all
31 teams in the league would be
horribly irresponsible any of the 30
other teams in the league would be
irresponsible
if they hadn't had internal discussions
who uh sees that a hall of fame wide
receiver
with some goodness
left in his career who would look at
that and say
now we have no interest even in
discussing it
i mean that's it's preposterous um
so i believe most teams have at least
discussed it
and look i think that at the end of the
day
you know new england makes an awful lot
of sense mike
it makes a lot of sense because bill
belichick has shown time and again
that he's not afraid of you go back to
randy moss in 07.
you know where everybody was staying
away from randy moss and he said i'll
take randy moss
and so to me i think the patriots really
make the most sense i have no idea if
they're going to be the team or not
i don't know who the team is going to be
but mike you said something early in
this
in this segment that you think there's a
good chance that it happens by wednesday
i don't know what day it's going to
happen but this trade is going to happen
you know the julio jones is not going to
be on the atlanta falcons
this trade is going to get done and in
my opinion it's the best thing for
everybody
it's the best thing for julio jones who
wants to find a new home
it's the best thing for the atlanta
falcons who need
cap relief over the coming years and
this won't be the only move they're
going to make
and i also think it's going to be a good
thing for whoever gets them because we
all
we see it we sum when he played last
year he is still
a magnificent player so to me
i think it's going to get done and it's
going to make sense
for the trading team and for the
acquiring team
you mentioned randy moss the league
thought he was washed up after his
second season with the raiders the
patriots basically stole him for a
fourth round pick
and he ended up having one of the
all-time great receiving
seasons in 2007 at the age of 30.
you mentioned that julio jones wants out
we hadn't heard from him until
shannon sharp committed state and
federal wiretapping violations earlier
this week by putting him on the air
without telling him he was on the air
and he said i'm out of there and the
falcons were livid about that that's one
of the reasons why i don't think the
falcons are sitting on a one
why be upset about your trade leverage
being affected by julio jones wishes
being broadcast to the world if you're
already sitting on an acceptable offer
and you're just waiting for something
better
if you got a first round pick in pocket
who cares what julio jones
says you know this is a done deal and if
someone else comes along that's your
leverage
what julio's comments did in my opinion
peter they took away the ability of the
falcons
to have an effective negotiation with
one team because if you're negotiating
with one
team and that team isn't giving you what
you want you can't say
credibly we'll just keep him because the
response is going to be
okay fine go ahead and keep the guy who
said
i'm out of there so that changed the
dynamic and it also unlocked reporting
on the reality that this has been
percolating for a while
and unlike these quarterback situations
where those players want out we didn't
know about this one
and mike i mean i i also think it just
shows the reality of trades
in 2021. you know
you have teams out there i'm sure that
are asking
uh fontenot and smith say listen we'd
love to give you a two for julio jones
but
we need money at the following level to
make this
happen and the falcons in that case
i'm pretty sure would rather just say
hey listen you know we're not
giving him away and then paying part of
the contract
and i think there have been other
contracts that teams basically
have taken a bite out of you know in
order to make it
palatable for the acquiring team and in
this particular case i think the falcons
are basically saying
absolutely no way we're going to do that
so i think that's part of this
i think the other part is quite honestly
just this simple fact that the atlanta
falcons
love julio jones the owner loves julio
jones
the and and so this is one of those
deals that
even though obviously now he wants out
and it's now it's clear you know it's on
the table that
this isn't just the falcons doing this
for cap relief they'd probably like to
do it too because they don't want a guy
in the first year of a new regime who
doesn't want to be there
so i i really think that it's going to
go
in the next week or so it's going to get
done
but i i just think there are some modern
parts
of this trade some modern tentacles that
still have to play out a little bit
yeah because again back to the original
item the report from thursday from espn
that the falcons have a first round pick
if that's true my guess would be
whoever's offering that first round pick
number one
expects to be pretty low in the round in
2022 and number two
quite possibly if not likely is
expecting the falcons to pick up
a sizable chunk of the 15.3 million
remember
when the panthers unloaded teddy
bridgewater onto the broncos for a sixth
round pick
they're still paying seven of 10 million
guaranteed to bridgewater this year
seven million being paid by the panthers
to make that trade happen so we'll see
where he goes what they get and i think
a very important factor as well
how much they pay
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports